je crois que vis à vis de 4 épices mme
bouchard y est exactement la même chose
l'opinion d'alain michel sur les
relations entre garçons et filles
exprimé bien souvent en termes très
libre nous l'avons fait écouter à
marielle et à frédéric marielle à 20 ans
frédéric 17
la première est de la nuit une amie
propriétaire d'une boîte à saint germain
des prés la seconde voudrait faire
l'école des cadres personnellement je
préfère une fille qui refuse parce que
ça prouve qu'elle a plus elle a plus de
volonté à la plus d'amour propre
alors mesdames qu'est ce que vous en
pensez ok les gars sont très égoïstes
c'est grotesque normative
personnellement je connais pas beaucoup
de filles qui sont vierges on connaît
pratiquement que je ne connais pas mais
non pourquoi est-ce que vous continuez à
les fréquenter
c'est normal c'est la vie c'est comme ça
et puis on fréquente qui défie non les
garçons qui ont fréquenté et grand mère
tous voulaient qu'on fréquente
vous savez pas un peu supérieure
oui certains oui vraiment oui et même
c'est ce sens de domination que que
j'aime chez j'aime bien les dominer
parce que sans supérieur on est aussi
aussi méchante que le font parce que eux
ed que dès qu'ils ont eu une fille et ça
y est on serre la main en vain merci ne
cherchez pas
parce que pour le moment ça m'intéresse
pas les hommes deux aiment bien les
petits minets comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces journées une mauvaise et enfin moi
je pense c'est mon avis qu'un garçon
sort avec une fille
premièrement enfin un garçon qui n'est
pas intéressé parce que si elle a
atterrés alors c'est l'argent de la
voiture ce qui s'en suit autrement faut
d'abord c'est physique chez une fille il
ya pas de raison comment pourrez-vous et
les autres voilà pour la galerie
exactement des bougies pour la galerie
parce qu'ils sont très jeunes et les
plus vieux c'est pas du tout comme ça
j'ai ont fréquenté ce moment ce qu'on
fait quand on fréquente des gens de 18 à
22 cents à 1,50 un japonais l'etic de 30
ans qui se foutent éperdument de la
boule très larges
non non non non il son premier film il
est généralement cierges plus long qui
leur donnent gagnant l'argent c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai parce que bon on
aime les gars si fidèle mois
lesquels mais moi j'aime les garçons
efféminés
je n'ai pas été viré
pourquoi
perso je serai plus mignon moi c'est
plus drôle
[Musique]
gameiro
ah l'amour
oui oui je vis la légère de me dire que
je suis complètement blasé alors quand
même pas du tout j'ai jamais été
vraiment si on était deux fois mon
analyse par beaucoup 17h02 faut beaucoup
beaucoup n'ont jamais vous c'est comme
ça assez banal c'est à dire que c'est
veut pas de l'amour ce puisque et au
plafond je suis mal placée au plafond
non parce que je suis une amoureuse tout
voilà je suis amoureuse tous les trois
jours
pourquoi est ce que je me lance et parce
qu'on essaye de rentrer en france
un peu comme les maires et ça fait du
bien croire ne pense à rien je ne pense
pas beaucoup non plus dans la journée
c'est un peu idiot de dire qu'on ne sait
rien
enfin je t'ai pas été c'est quand on
sent que tout le monde ne pense à rien
même ceux qui sont autour de vous je
sais pas je sais pas exactement pourquoi
m'enfin c'est une sorte d'euphorie qu'on
peut pas quand on n'est pas en train de
comprendre ça peut pas s'expliquer les
beaux mariages
[Musique]
c'est merveilleux danse et les amis
quant à steve on défonce on oublie tout
est très mal je suis très paresseux
alors
marc angers 1 peuvent être moins
paresseux que les marais
bah oui je suis né je pense que ça parle
pas changé
très bien le lent très long terme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ressemble à mes parents ah non pas du
tout à ma mère
pas parce qu'ils ont pas du tout à une
conception de la vie moi d'abord c'est
une génération avant alors c'est pas dit
fut la même chose leur mode de vie sont
toujours à me raconter quand j'étais
jeune quand j'étais jeune je m'en fiche
moi quand j'étais jeune moi c'est ma
génération je vis avec moi avec ma
génération
[Musique]
non
à
[Musique]